two one and we are live for the day guys
welcome to the corridor cast welcome
back I mean man it's been almost a week
maybe it's been a little bit longer than
a week and we are just so excited
because we are all starting to get cabin
fever here oh yeah with that I got a
couple topics couple questions that I
want to throw out there to the group
really now okay hear me out if you have
been on quarantine and you're starting
to feel a little bit like you know your
minds starting to wander feeling a
little bit of cabin fever I've got a
good game to play okay
imagine that you found a genie right
okay you're following but working on it
yep you know about genies right there
sir ecology and folklore you know that
can grant you wishes things of that
nature now imagine this it's not a
regular genie though are they the genie
is a modern billionaire and they can
only grant you wishes using the powers
that they actually have in real life no
imagine you get a genie and it's Elon
Musk or Jeff Bezos it's Jeff Bezos
[Laughter]
but he can only grant you wishes that
he's actually capable of doing what
would you ask
Elon yeah it's happened billion dollars
first and foremost okay so nice to have
he'd have to sell all of his stock but
he could do it though
yeah this 50 he achieves today right
like he has to have already achieved it
today well he doesn't have to have
achieved it necessarily but he has to be
capable of do
it currently you know Jake sound like a
smarmy ass answer but in reality there's
nothing that Elon Musk has that I want
[Laughter]
[Music]
by the way you should probably know
who's on this podcast it's Nico
obviously we've got Christian and also
we've got Matt who's have been on the
corridor caspo
in fact I've never been on a podcast
ever in general so yeah I'm a huge
liability yesterday you look like you're
a shape for this I look good oh yeah
yeah how does one do like it she hates
it you gotta embrace it man you gotta
embrace it yeah I like it yeah I think
Matt needs a quick little introduction
here so Matt is one of the editors here
at corridor back we did the the hiring
back in wasn't springtime and a spring
last year that's when he found Matt and
Dean so Matt is a wonderful editor he's
knows his way around some graphics and
visual effects as well and he was also
one of the lead personalities in the who
shot the TV video yeah by the way did
you guys hear that
LG is sending us another TV thanks to
Christians hard work it's close the guy
would be an occasional announcement but
we're close to maybe two TVs will see LG
if you're listening please don't stop
sending the TVs just as I said it too
early you know you want to LG you know
you want to so you know I wanted to talk
about Tiger King yeah yeah I've answered
your Genie question I
I do I like a whole topic of discussion
oh I totally can't for me I I will say
that happening my own personal spaceship
would be pretty sweet I because I can
you imagine being a person that has gone
to space there are very few people in
the world that can say they've gone to
space so like having one that I can just
take and do whatever I want with super
cool
I would also need like a team of you
know engineers and scientists that could
get me there but yes the link is the
awesome right it seems like a liability
to ask for a spaceship though it's kind
of like you know a jetliner it's like
that's cool but then you can't fly it or
do anything with it that's why in my
wish I would include the the engineers
and astronauts that would help me yeah
include it's like when you win a car but
and they also give you like a suitcase
full of cash so you can pay for the tax
on the car so you can pay for the taxes
and stuff yeah yeah look question does
it have to be Elon Musk er can we switch
the genie over to Bezos because either
let's hear it let's hear what happened I
mean one day and he went on to
amazon.com and he ordered genie and then
Amazon credits man for sure okay could
do that for you yeah I just wanna
forever you know
just clearing the cart balance on Amazon
because I'd be useful perpetual cart
balance oh yeah you definitely gonna
start there cuz I think you know
obviously right now it's a little weird
but I think down the line or you know
when things are back up everyone's using
Amazon so what if you did what if you
spent all your wishes on just that stuff
though so that you just had really good
Amazon service but like you didn't do
anything else like I just got free
Amazon sector
find it on Amazon yeah you don't have to
order the new releases anymore you can
just get them yeah right
feel like that would be a waste yeah I
mean we get one I mean that would be
just wish one out of three right yeah
yeah thank you
free free Amazon okay see what else can
that billionaire do what else can that
guy do kind of anything he has like his
own government he doesn't play by any
rules I feel like the catch though of
this question it just comes down to how
much money the person has it's like it's
kind of all they can really do is either
give you money or pay somebody else to
do something but yeah you can just take
that up a step and just give me the
money and I'll pay them to do something
because it's true
see like now if it was like a wonderful
artist or musician isn't like that
you know maybe I could play a song for
me or whatever I don't know you know
like bard play a song you open your next
bottle oh my god Shakira Shakira how
much is she worth we bottle sorry
modern Christina Aguilera I went with
that with all of her exquisite
incredible powers I don't know I'm not
really in a celebrity culture yeah yeah
know what I would ask a very even if I
just ran into her the street and I did
its little pomp music you have to our
wishes like I wish your freedom like you
don't use it to it like just leave
please
I wish making music you lost all your
memory of your music career
so are you guys watching Tiger King I
don't yeah everybody apparently is and
apparently it's a romp on white-trash
culture that's what I very much very
much like two episodes left but you know
I want I wanted to ask you guys his
opinion on something so we're okay all
right Joe exotic right I think we can
all well first off can we all agree that
he's a scumbag he's a scummy person we
all agree with that
oh yeah everybody i can assume as much
he's not from florida the twisted he's
from Oklahoma the reason why I hesitated
it's not because he's not a scumbag
because he is in fact that scumbag it's
like what where's the question going
because they're all scumbags
yeah every last one of them so my
question it it goes a little bit further
here so I think there's one thing that
that this Joe fella wants more than
anything else in the world its Fame and
attention right so we all got to enjoy
this documentary we all got to go on
this story romp but in the process we're
giving this guy who is by most accounts
not a good person what exactly what do
you want exactly what he learned so is
there a responsibility that we or the
documentarian filmmakers have in this
case like take it back a step so there's
the guy that was doing the reality show
halfway through and had that reality
show come out I imagine it would have
been just the same thing what was on MTV
back and think we've been like The
Osbournes
you know but for what this guy instead
basically making him a celebrity and
cashing in on how kooky and how much of
a scumbag he is but with no real
downsides it's just you know is there a
reason he is in prison he's now but not
because so video about them I basically
didn't this happen with honey boo boo
alright I don't know but my point with
this here's a question it's a question
is this at which point do you guys think
it's okay to
watching something for entertainment
when you are helping the person who is
an [ __ ] get what they want in the
process so like sure that's a bad
example and the documentary filmmakers
been [ __ ] themselves by making Joe
exotic a star even though he's you know
a sexual-assault
slash animal brights guy who points guns
at people and gets dudes hooked on meth
the question is then for me how many
people actually like him like you know
go oh my god Joe exotic is my favorite
you know I wanna get Joe exotic t-shirts
now oh and his underwear and it's
condoms probably the same people that
think the corona virus is a hoax
so exactly that's probably a little
person how many people watch the show
now you know if a hundred million people
have watched a show and one percent like
show exotic that's a million people like
now it's a million available that
believe in flat earth and you know
chemtrails and stuff like that I mean
there's there's plenty of those people
out there that are just you know crazy
anyway yeah well this doesn't matter
what you feed them this is what reality
TV has spawned I mean since Survivor
yeah you're putting yeah awful people up
on the pedestal and honestly rewarding
of them for their offered awful behavior
with more attention the whole show
Survivor which spawned the reality TV
revolution was based upon how horrible
people could be to each other I mean in
effect there's but but at the end of the
day the worst guy one and the right is
willing he's willing to lie cheat beg
borrow and steal more than anybody else
was in order to win true so there is the
flip side which is the human condition
and learning about ourselves right you
know you take this one like extreme of a
human being who is not a good person and
in watching that person burn out in a
spectacular fashion we all learn a
little bit about ourselves because
inside each and every one of us is just
a little bit joe exotic
I mean he speaks a little bit to that
like that inner it'd you know like the
part of you that you ideally outgrew
when you were four years old you know
and you learned how to have self-control
and things like that and empathy
you know the answer for sure I mean it's
the thing is there's also like the
there's there's another side to this and
the documentary definitely it goes a
long way especially at the end and now
you haven't seen the last two episodes
Nico but they definitely hit a lot
harder on the the exotic animal trade
and how bad it is there's this whole
like they go into this whole issue with
like the legal system and how it's like
really skewed and Jake I'm sure you
haven't perspective on this as well but
there's like what's the statistic it's
like three hundred three thousand five
hundred there are three thousand five
hundred Tigers in the wild versus five
thousand in America alone that are in
captivity no there's more yeah that was
the main thing they were harping on was
if there's more in captivity than there
are even left in the wild
yeah and that's that's Harry's animals
trade is is a real is a real issue
because there's there's a whole slate of
countries that are between well I mean I
guess they're third-world but like you
take a country like Mexico for example
technically what there's this whole term
third-world right was originated from US
and Russia being and then everything
else so it's not really like a good term
but basic basic thing is what I'm trying
to say is you take a you take a country
that's not at the progressive edge of
like animal rights and things like that
right like Mexico is just an example in
pretty much every one of those countries
you can buy elephant boots and Tiger fur
and whatever you want if you want to buy
there's a market for it I mean and so
there's a yeah when it comes to like
that kind of stuff I don't know that
there's there's really no stopping that
unless everybody gets on board but
there's always gonna be a poor like last
better off country that someone's gonna
stand a profit from it and isn't gonna
have to deregulation or the
infrastructure to enforce any of it so
sure yeah did you guys see that serious
I can't remember if it's like Vogue or
wired but you know there's all the like
the ask a professional thing I mean it's
you know there's a whole like CIA guy
breaks down five spy movies or visual
effects artists react to effects and
there was what I saw was like a mob boss
breaks down mob films and like I looked
that and just it left a bad taste in my
mouth because like this is a guy who's
like a villain you know he's he's the
person when you watch her mom movie like
that guy's an [ __ ] he's a criminal
he's a shady person he's probably done
shitty things and now here he is being
rewarded and idolized for being a mob
boss and like that really rubs me the
wrong way it's like my stings like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] that guy
like why should he be like you know
rewarded for that and like cuz people
love a rebel Nico yeah man yeah they
love it people don't think people are
real and I watch my two people like
Joe's not a real person or Carroll
Basson's on a real person they're
characters in a movie make your
characters yeah yeah so you that's what
they're portrayed as when you're
watching these things they're just like
oh my god that's so ridiculous how I
would never be like that that's just a
character yeah it's weird
it's like I mean that that's that's like
the epitome of mob movies is the whole
idea of of like oh look at how you know
this mobster is when they go out and be
a bad guy I'm sure well then it's like
who do you blame I mean obviously these
entertainment companies are trying to
make entertaining content and obviously
they're finding the documentaries like
tiger king or they're going to find that
mob boss to go react to this thing do
you blame them too I mean it's really
it's done that or is it their fault is
it mainly their followers at the
audience because they all want to see
that stuff you know it's yeah yeah it's
like the drug war man as a person hit my
tires you know you're sitting down
you're firing up Netflix and you're
giving them 10 bucks and you're watching
that that movie or that documentary
series you're going it's okay for you to
make this watch yeah I've spent whatever
I mean I got it done and like to you I'm
the only one who hasn't seen it yeah
well you haven't seen it tick okay
because not because I haven't like
thought about seeing and I just did I
just haven't taken the time to watch it
I can't be in a binge watch it it's
actually too much for me like one
episode leaves me in a weird head space
I only did it in three chunks though
because it was like I don't know it's a
story that is so captivating to me just
awful and but there's a reason why it's
like extremely popular right now because
it is this like it's it's this crazy
world that you've never entered before
and you're you know kind of seeing it
through the eyes of these insane people
and it's the same way with like you know
like a show like Breaking Bad where you
you have this character that you're like
oh maybe I like him at first but then
you uncover certain things about this
character that you're following and it's
like by the end of it you don't like the
guy you know you might have watched him
through his journey but you you I think
a general audience goes oh this isn't
these aren't people I should be liking
you know yeah so I hope that that's the
case for a lot of people that watch it
and they they come come away with like
you know more awareness for the exotic
trade industry and and how messed up it
is right now but at the same time it is
also an entertaining thing and I
understand why people would just have
that kind of value from it but yeah I
mean my biggest takeaway is that if it's
a private Zoo that lets you pet the
animals not like a petting zoo be like
but the Uyghurs then they're scumbags
then it's not a real
yeah exactly and I think it does a good
job of like showing out just because
there's a different face on it doesn't
make it a different thing yeah you know
like Carroll zoo doesn't isn't better
than Joe exotic zoo because it is it or
did the door do the documentary
filmmakers just need to have an
antagonist for the story it's me you
don't I don't I don't I don't
necessarily know but I know that
documentaries any documentary has to
take a side so like this is something
they had to be on one side or the other
of this but I do think that they did
something unique with this where they're
not on the side of anyone in the
documentary you know yeah they're on the
side of what's wrong about all of this I
do I do feel like they're
misrepresenting Carroll just a little
bit for the sake of having possibly
technically I don't know enough about
Carroll or her business well I mean
everybody has the same mentality that
Carroll is a [ __ ] right everybody sure
she's the most crazy cat lady you'll
ever meet for sure she is by far the
most liked cat lady she is way out there
yeah but there's a couple things that
like when you step back and look at it's
like one she doesn't let people pet them
- she doesn't buy them three she doesn't
breed them and so it's like looking at
that it's like the the documentary tried
to tries to equate her with the other
people and I feel like it's just doing
that for the sake of making you feel
like there's you know good guy and bad
guy that are an equal playing playing
fields here but I can't help but feel
like a documentary filmmakers are
playing with somebody's life you know
like not only me like in the sense of
like oh they'll you know she'll get
murdered but more in the sense that like
you know they're casting her in a
certain light for their story whether or
not it's necessarily honest and it's
going to affect a real person and it's
going to affect their real life but
isn't this isn't its topic though this
general philosophy that we're talking
about here isn't this inherent in all
entertainment not in like fiction I
guess but you're still composing name
name a pop a great feeling even if it's
fiction though if it's good fiction it's
believable and
not necessarily like a one-to-one I
could step into that world right now but
the character is in the situation in the
setting and like the potential for each
of the characters is real yeah
add another people and that's what makes
good fix truce it's a reflection of real
life yeah let's make you know the human
the human condition but it's not like if
you go watch a movie and Danny Trejo as
the villain you don't leave it going boy
Danny Trejo I hate that guy I'm gonna
write him hate mail and boycott the
actress that played Cersei in Game of
Thrones and she was making some of those
bad moves during those seasons she would
tell stories of people walking down the
street would just be like you're a total
[ __ ] or like I can't believe you did
that and she's like it's a character I
played but people get so invested I'm
not actually a queen so invested to the
character that that's who you are to
them yeah sure enough when I'm what I
was getting at even whether or not it's
fiction or nonfiction in order for it to
be compelling and neat you need story
you need challenges every character is
perfect it's not interesting and so yeah
so yeah so that's kind of what you're
beholden to because that's what humans
are inherently interested in and I don't
know why that is necessarily we all what
we are
it speaks I mean so everything I'm
swearing out there's a little bit of
devil's advocate because in reality it's
also really important to learn about the
human condition to learn about these
extremes and you know if somebody like
Joe exact does gain some of the famous
looking for but in return we all learn a
little bit more about how to be better
people in the process like it can offset
itself a little bit yeah yeah I saw that
admit that I didn't know much about that
exotic animal trade world at all like
that and yeah like you said you see
examples they need to also see what not
to be like and so obviously some of the
way Joe treated partners in his life and
his employees you know every time I said
it's just it becomes disgusting to me
and it's like wow like I wouldn't I you
know I couldn't see myself going that
way and treating a human being like that
but yet there are people out there that
are that are and do I think it as a
documentary was a little bit more
responsible than something like
blackfish which was very very much on
one side and kind of crippled SeaWorld's
business for a long time now a lot of
people were like okay with that they're
like yeah you know take down SeaWorld
but they do they do actually do good
things for animals they're you know they
do they do rehabilitation for animals
there and that was taking down a lot of
their business and it was such a skewed
perspective so I don't know is it is it
better is it worse to me to me it
doesn't seem like it but yeah I mean
there's the question the other question
that's important to ask here which is
this advice blackfish - yeah why do we
give a [ __ ] about Tigers and we have
millions of cows locked up that gets
slaughtered every day and these pens
like sure it's really hypocritical
honestly for us to give a crap about
frickin Orca or a tiger when there's you
know we have Tigers are not bred by
human beings and domesticated by human
beings to be slaughtered that's not
going to be like yes releasing them is
one thing like that's definitely a thing
but like so let's say you did breed
Tigers to slaughter them for their fur
or whatever for their meat I don't know
let's say Tiger burgers became a big
thing like my point being is that like
why are we getting upset about tigers in
captivity when we're aren't we aren't
upset about parrots in captivity or cows
in captivity or pigs in captivity or you
know like aquariums like
yeah you know dragons dragons parents no
bearded dragons oh yeah you know you
you mean like non domesticated animals
that are in pet stores yeah I mean I
guess I'll really consider livestock to
be domesticated so I consider they are
being bred for the new livestock is
absolutely a domesticated animal yeah I
was I used esta kated as a definition of
a pet the animal has been made to be a
pet but yeah you're right it's didn't
live stalks domesticated too but is that
just like some arbitrary thing that
decides whether now it's okay to have
the animal in captivity
I mean people take some people take good
care of their Tigers you know like Mike
Tyson Joe seemed to take good care of
his Tigers at least up to the point
where I'm at in the series Big Freedia
boys I think they're about exotic
animals in general in an ecosystem where
they don't belong is that if those
animals get out then they can ruin that
ecosystem right now it's general
practice to not bring an animal that
doesn't belong in that ecosystem for
that environment to that environment so
that's I know that's one thing that is
that can be an issue yeah I don't mean
to be an expert on that there aren't any
hard and fast rules about this because
it's not like there's a new thing that
all the sudden humans have been
introduced to as some new technology or
like cars where it's like okay
everyone's got a car now we better come
up with some rules of the road humans
have been interacting with other animals
of all species for sense forever and so
I think maybe there the way that you
feel about whether where that line is in
terms of like what's okay to keep and
what's not okay to keep is is there's
absolutely a gray area because
some people are like yeah what man is
here to do whatever he wants to do and
you can just take whatever you want to
take and that's all it is man we're all
gonna die whatever some people are like
no you know it's a much more like the
cooperative relationship with animals
and you know there's ones that are
domesticated over thousands of years and
there's ones that we rely on and there's
ones that we don't and you know yeah
there's definitely a gray area where is
the line at for you what would be an
animal that would be okay to keep and
what would be an animal that would not
be okay to keep I mean like so this
would have to be like a research based
thing where it's like okay if I were to
want this lemur for example is this Li
its this lemur that's you know I'll just
swear by the way I don't even know I was
about to say a swear
but you swear it if it happens it
happens but don't intentionally okay
cool
now I know how to podcast if I have a
lemur that's F and around my house you
know I want to know if that lemur if it
gets out if that's gonna be detrimental
to the ecosystem right so that would be
my one thing I guess and also like just
general you know care for that animal am
I properly caring for that animal
what's a lemur again I'm gonna look this
out they got a ringtail here we go
I think in the imagination if there's a
lot of annals that'd be theoretically
cool but if you just think with a
logical mind it's like eventually it's
gonna either outgrow or become
aggressive or yeah not work as a pet
because like yeah sure I think having a
chimp would be super cool but I think
eventually and there's a point where
it's not possible and it terrible dude
there's a woman in Minnesota who got her
face ripped off by a chimpanzee yeah
but chimpanzee I know even like if you
had the resources and you had the space
and everything but at the same time
they're so intelligent that unless you
were studying it for the purposes of
advancing humanity I really don't think
that there'd be a good reason to keep
one because they belong in a group in
the wild that's so what and and it's
gonna be very hard to like I mean people
do it there are people that have chimps
and there are champs in captivity that
we study all the time every day and they
have relationships with humans but I
feel like unless it's for that end
probably best in the wild yeah it would
be my default I think that you can apply
this approach any wild animal if it's a
wild animal putting it in captivity it's
kind of a cruel thing to do you know
what about a snake though see snakes
don't really have brains and I think
bugs and to an extent reptiles start to
get to a point look you're taking good
care of it that that changes things
somewhat it's not you know none of this
is ever really black and white like oh I
have a captive tiger but I also have a
one mile ranch for him to roam on and I
you know I there's there's only gray
areas here like you know people can
could take good care of captive animals
but I think just getting a wild animal
making it a captive animal and then
using that for your social media to get
views that's yeah well what would be it
would be an exotic animal let's let's
get a little bit deeper here what would
be an exotic animal that you'd be okay
keeping I just know about lemurs man I
was mine doesn't automatically
eventually go to like no that doesn't
work or that's cruel I mean it's like
well you can give conditions you can put
conditions on it there's no right answer
here as we've previously established
this is a gray area
I feel like insects and reptiles are
fair game to a certain extent well sort
of but there wasn't there this the thing
I'm thinking about when I'm talking
about detrimental to an ecosystem is
like I think there was this case where
they brought in a bunch of flower frogs
to
a place in I believe it was in Florida I
could be totally getting this wrong by
the way but they they introduced these
this species of frogs into this
ecosystem to get rid of their insects
their mosquito problem and those frogs
multiplied like crazy right and because
of this it ruined the ecosystem of that
environment right so like stuff like
that is something you need to consider
even with really small animals like that
if they multiply like crazy then they
can you know they can kick it really
harm assuming it doesn't affect the
ecosystem okay just just on the merits
we assumed that it was not one reptile
might be worth thinking about Komodo
dragon things are crazy scary yeah
there's like have venomous spit I think
so yeah they can they can yeah baby cat
baby baby deer and stuff there's like a
great pet and when they confront each
other - they do they're like hit each
other with so much power those things
are crazy yeah those things can kill a
human pretty easily yeah I don't I mean
oh yeah I don't know if there's an
exotic animal I can think of that I'd
want as a pet I mean it's kind of crazy
I mean you didn't want to have a tiger
yeah but the things are not domesticated
you want to turn oh there's no debate
yeah that's a thing like if you could
domesticate a wild animal then be like
it'd be cool to have like a you know a
cat sized dog sorry a dog sized cat you
know like that would be cool
I like the demeanor of cats but like it
needs to be domesticated so I guess
that's the problem they're like just
getting a wild animal and be like look
at this wild beast I have like there's
nothing that like really pulls me in
even domesticated cats are derived from
a wild cat that was not very much bigger
than that - yeah and they get down from
Tigers supposing cats never really
domesticated it's just they've always
kind of been that way like they
naturally evolved to be chill around
people because it led to them getting
more food and whatnot yeah it was like a
yeah they domesticated themselves are
that's breeding them well I guess we've
bred them at this one
but initially they kind of just did it
yes well yeah yeah I think every species
that evolved differently to you know
like you think about horses or cattle or
pigs X can go feral and in a couple
generations again really yeah yeah
that's how that's why there's so many
feral hogs throughout like the entire
southeast as as they're all pigs that
aren't original to the area that became
feral huh hmm if I could domesticate a
Lynx I would totally have one those cats
are so cool that's a cool dad yeah good
one you need a lot of and what does
Carroll say shark yeah
depends on how big your areum is there
and you have a giant aquarium and you
have a shark look at the fish can't tell
the difference
no who cares shark would be okay look if
you can take care of a lion to the Mora
Tiger to the point that it's you know
like it's in the wild and sure have a
pet tiger a lion too but like that's
what like 2% of the population that
actually can do that like yeah yeah I
mean the 70s Bond villain yeah the shark
I mean the whole goal of having a wild
animal wouldn't be for you to pet it and
like hang out with it and Alice is
everybody's quarantine going house
working from home working out is that
can we run for door from home wherever
every puts in extra hours I've noticed
including me we're all working like
10-hour days in that work I'm more
spread out you know yeah that's just the
nature of it but it's also you don't
seem as bothered by it or whatever
to do like so you're kind of splitting
it up between these other
brakes yeah do you think it's because we
can't do anything else right now I think
it's because you can just sit down and
start working right away I mean I think
the reality is all of us like our job
you know it stills at times it still
worked but like you know I didn't
I'm not grudgingly a filmmaker since we
can't since we're not really supposed to
do anything else I think that's that
that can help a lot of people cope with
it because I think if this was just the
normal and the option to go out or go
hang out with friends or just be out and
doing things yeah was an option
I think distractions you know are that
that just makes my way more distractions
and then obviously you're not really
tracking everybody because you're you
know working together and you know know
if they're out or whatever yeah that
kind of helps I think obviously being in
quarantine knowing that kind of
everybody's in quarantine together that
definitely kind of helps the whole like
cabin fever slash you know we're all in
this together type of thing yeah go
ahead work from home company if we were
just like a type of company that does
work remote and works from home but
everything else was kind of normal I
think you do you would probably get into
those situations you kind of fall off or
taper off or start to build up
distractions to where yeah you might
start getting less efficient yeah you
need the right culture around it
yeah yeah I think we've done a good job
I've been pleasantly surprised but there
is yeah there is something to be said
for like physical interaction filming in
the same space yeah I like the student
for sure but at the same time I think
this has been a good insight and that it
isn't one thing's for sure our studio is
not the type of place where it is
absolutely necessary to our business
that everyone is in the same physical
space working it together all of the
time as a couple weeks proved it yeah
yeah I would I would be interested in
like a hybrid version of this where it's
like maybe
for two days out of the week we don't
necessarily have to go into the studio
if we're just editing but I don't know
it would still probably be a little bit
more complicated because you still have
to take your stuff back and forth and
yada yada
but yeah I mean I'm certainly like I the
other thing is it's each individual -
and this is no this is no qualms against
I don't know what he's doing half the
time anyway company that we can do this
I mean eventually we got to start doing
corridor productions again and obviously
we're talking about it like as soon as
late next week or early the week after
we're gonna have to get a skeleton crew
together and film some var together or
react videos together yeah so that's not
like we're completely were able just
come you know never have to continue to
do this without ever getting together
but I think it's there's definitely been
a good experiment to see like there's
aspects of it and there's times maybe
where it it's not as big of a deal but
then there's you know and have like
editing deliverables that they have to
do and they got a that there's no Moffat
because that's the thing that's very
measurable and that's what I like about
it too is it's like okay you're gonna
edit from home okay well at this time in
this inbox and so go get it done yeah
focus better station or whatever like
I've done more editing over the last -
yes you have yeah yeah so it's stuff
like that where it's tangible but if
it's just like hey I'm gonna work from
home today and it's like well what are
you gonna do um well I'll figure it out
once I'm back
yeah coming to the studio if you're
gonna do that but I could see people
editing from home more often because
especially on the studio floor where
it's really loud yeah I can't do
anything out there except for film and
be loud sure
we need a spot to film be allowed at
some point exactly yeah
it's part of the business but not having
everyone in there all the time might
help with some of that sure yeah and
just being able to like Lincoln and do
your work and not have any kind of chaos
distractions going on yeah it's
definitely more efficient so yeah yeah
it definitely can help
I mean we all took to the disc or very
well we're all basically chatting with
each other all day still yeah
needed and so it's been cool to see how
we adapt but ya know obviously in my
role like yeah I can already feel myself
getting pretty soon I'm gonna be like
okay let's get on the set somewhere like
let's we're gonna have to put the DJI
thing like yeah like oh yeah there's
demo on the field and like be capturing
some content soon but like you know but
then there's also yeah the other aspect
where is like yeah I'm actually like
getting back to a lot of brand people on
the side and doing a lot more email
types of administrative stuff again
because that's like there's no
distraction going on there's not you
know the smash break or the film session
or whatever it is but then there's that
half of my role which is like I'm gonna
be ready to like let's go film some
stuff like in person and put a crew
together to do stuff yeah well to wrap
things up you guys want to talk some
projections here some coronavirus
projections kick it kick it off this
morning from MSNBC the most trusted news
in networks
and what the article was was it was
basically like the headline of it was
coronavirus more deaths than 9/11 and I
looked at that yeah no [ __ ]
and I was like
why would you make the comparison to 911
an isolated incident right a terrorist
attack that has in one news media that's
why it is like such a sizzling juicy
header and I think this actually goes
back to when we were talking about the
tiger King and like responsibilities in
the media right cuz they do they have a
responsibility to like put out content
that's I don't know ethically true or
some they there's some code of ethics
that they should follow right so that
people people's opinions aren't skewed
and yeah this was one of those things
where I was like I looked at it and I
was like man this is this is like true
fear mongering yeah no you're completely
right like when the outbreak was
starting I would go to cnn.com and like
the headlines were like they're just so
garbage like yeah you know for example
you know people start dying the
quarantine starts up city starts saying
you know I had to tell you where to say
at home and the headline is you know got
or Republicans versus Democrats fight
over stimulus bill and like it's just
turning into a sports showdown you know
because everybody's got their teams that
they're that they're voting for but like
that's how it should have been about at
all like who cares about partisanship
right now is they like deal with that
like people eventually they had about it
because it was it was so uncouth they
were all like oh hey maybe we shouldn't
be bipartisan for a few minutes vote on
a bill yeah
but then like you know just going to see
an editor I figure out in you know
numbers or like hey where'd you go to
get tested or other you know valuable
informative things like it was just
non-existent so then I went to you know
LA Times and New York Times actually and
just like the quality of reporting was
so starkly different like and those are
sites you have to pay for sure rotavirus
coverage stuff is free by the way if you
just like an account you can read
anything about the coronavirus for free
but like boy what a world of difference
it makes to have either a subscriber
base versus trying to get your headlines
through sheer viral clicks like yeah man
one sensationalist the other ones
informative and it's just night and day
difference and boy oh boy has the
advertising based revenue of places like
CNN does totally ruined journalism for
those places or I know yeah
yeah that's that's one of the greatest
difficulties that we currently face with
respect to news and information is the
ad model that it's based on when it is
based on clicks there's just man you
know at least there was with with
subscription there's a little bit more
integrity there and I'm hoping that we
can get back to some of that stuff over
the next decade here because it's rough
out there right now man like this with
people has to be a cultural change
people need to like acknowledge that
it's good to pay for some things right
yeah it seems like in the comments of
this even this article that I was
mentioning there's 9/11 in comparison
there is a heavy leaning in the comments
like hey this is fear-mongering and this
is wrong okay so I think I think there's
a lot of people that that are starting
to see that and yeah and it is it's like
it's like should these big media outlets
these news outlets should they be
following the same principles as like a
youtube title for their to get more
views and clicks yeah even youtubers
have ethical even youtubers should have
a standard for that like yeah it is as
much of a joke as you just made is
that's actually happening though they're
looking at yeah they're looking at
platforms like YouTube and they're going
oh they're getting more views than us so
what do we do it's like and then you're
starting to get like the young uns who
are coming up through college and like
our college marketing and then they're
coming in and they're like oh we should
use these use these new techniques to
brand our stories check these out and
then use that you see those two things
grow closer and that's not necessarily a
good thing
now well I'm making the call right now
Matt in one week you're gonna see a 911
every day as a TED heaven every day
right we're at 6,000 deaths per day so
give it a week and we'll be at juicy
juicy title I would click on that video
I'm gonna have a really good thumbnail
for us to like the virus is burning
humans
it's just a bunch of Twin Towers burning
the twin towers are organizing a lottery
yeah or every calendar day projections
here we go guys all right I got some
pulled up from Axios calm cool so right
now the peak in California the closest
we would like the the best off possible
peak that we could have right now will
happen on April 11 that's if everything
goes perfectly and somehow everybody
stays home and stops having parties like
April 11th is the soonest we could hit
our peak
this one says April 26th that's the
that's the realistic projected peak is
April 26th and that's that's accounting
just if everybody can get their [ __ ]
together and really followed by the
guidelines then we should taper off ever
be at the top and not go any higher
actually even people don't get their
[ __ ] together the peak will still be
around April 26
it'll just be twice as many people dying
versus the other one people have to the
same point but if we manage to somehow
get on top of it sooner the the the
soonest the peak could possibly happen
in California is April 11th I also see
this as as us nationally as April 14th
yes April 14th is currently the u.s. one
now once again the soonest we could peak
in the US would be April 10th that's the
that's if once again things go really
well but that's not gonna happen because
half the states still aren't taking this
seriously and they will once a thousand
people die oh did you exactly did you
see the there was some research foot out
it was on posted on the reddit mega
thread counting in cases that aren't
reported yes it looks like from what
this research agency was able to come up
with the actual death rate is like point
six six percent yeah that's what it in
Korea it's 0.7 and Korea's sprout pretty
good numbers so you're right it's
probably around 0.6 point that's still a
lot by the way
is that what you're saying you know the
uh rather than trying to go by number
total number of deaths is the most
accurate thing like you might not know
who's diagnosed but he doesn't know he's
dying from and yeah yeah I mean I'm
right now the the lowest peak for deaths
in the United States for daily deaths
will be one and a half thousand so if we
do the possible best we can on April
10th one and a half thousand people will
be dying every day from this April 16th
is the projected average
middle-of-the-road one that's 2600
people dying a day just for you know a
couple days of the peak and then this
you know 1500 a day for a while and then
the biggest peak the highest peak right
now would be 2500 a day now obviously
that could get screwed up and go even
higher but uh yeah people are gonna get
the [ __ ] kicked out of them by this for
a little while and yeah I'm really
disappointed to see I saw some a fist
bump today did I did I disapprove with
them quietly and internally very hard
maybe they use hand sanitizer right
after or before they just like sanitize
bumps yeah Wow it's gonna be a little
gnarly and he said that people need to
be contrarian about it but you know
whatever
like I said before with freedom comes
responsibility but no one's seen not no
one but a lot of people seem to think
that with freedom comes you saying [ __ ]
you I do what I want with your freedom
comes also the need for you to be here
speaking of freedom when's when's the
economy gonna come back online here
because how many of these stimulus bills
can they can they realistically release
here I mean the thing is it should come
online I would assume by around June
July the reality is that's crazy yeah
life you know whatever it happens what
happens like
you know you'll get through it and you
start doing your work again what else is
gonna do like it's not the end of the
world
to be laid off the end of the world is
when you die the end of the world is
getting around a virus and dying because
you can't use more serious getting laid
off sucks but it's like we it's not like
the the housing crisis where there's
like a vast like foundational element
that's messed up in arses like economic
structure like we know what's causing
that the problem here it's pretty clear
what's causing the economic problem the
worst thing about recessions is that
they is about is that they have a
compounding effect yeah but you get out
of them eventually to I mean to a
certain extent you know with the wind
the US economy has grown over the past
13 years I believe it is like it's
almost more concerning that we haven't
had like a bear market or a recession
then like so in a way like this might
help them relieve some of that steam and
some of that pressure and I'm just
talking out of my ass here so please
listen kids yeah honestly that sentiment
was see it was seen last year at the
beginning of the year when all the stock
markets went yeah and then like oh wait
there's not gonna be recession okay cool
more yeah they took off again yeah
everything's gonna happen and it's like
nothing's changed why are you guys so
worried like things are going the same
way as they always have been and
everything oh yes China war China tear
for did you guys see that video that was
the conspiracy theories Corona
conspiracy theories Oh
give them to me just say this guys one I
love conspiracies - they're all [ __ ]
but you know they're all wrong I love
the Imaginationland that they take you
in all right so conspiracy theory is
that
there's a lab in Wuhan that studies
viruses because they've had numerous
viruses come from like bats and other
animals so it's trying to actually have
had labs working on this stuff for a
while
and supposedly they'd actually found the
corona virus back in like November and
then when the lab people got infected
with it and then it got out my god no so
this could potentially be a Chinese not
lab grown virus but a virus that's been
extracted in the lab and then it got out
there security measures weren't tight
enough and it got out and it
contaminated oh yeah anything is
possible with the Chinese over there but
doubt it highly unlikely that's the
whole thing about conspiracies man this
is is you don't want to believe that
something so simple could affect so many
people yeah it's gotta be it's gotta be
under someone's control right yeah
things don't just happen right guys yeah
it's like right yeah viruses do just
happen and you know sure somebody may
have like you know even the bat or
coughed on the other person to like you
know go from patients here at a patient
one but that shit's gonna happen anyways
you know it's gonna happen at some point
it's just I think people just want a
villain to you know it's a better story
if you got someone to blame yeah this is
a tie back to the beginning god we're
filmmakers you know it's probably a good
point for us to actually wrap this up at
Dean's Dean's waiting on me I need to
record a voiceover for a new merch
launch by the way so he's probably
sitting there like with his hands
interested we just restocked a bunch of
stuff on the store it's a store we got a
mocap crewneck up there we got a green
screen emergency blanket oh sorry Matt
back here also if you guys are on the
website if you're a website member you
get 15% off
all the time every day of every all the
time that the subscription could
literally pay for itself with like one
order from the store good yeah cool
alright everybody thanks for listening
to the core cast we hope to see you in
the next one go ahead and check out
corridor digital dot store if you want
some that merch that crew neck is very
very popular and sells out very fast and
getting this stuff takes some time right
now so it's there if you want it please
consider supporting us sanitizer bumps I
put hand sanitizer I'm a computer
because I had a virus alright guys good
stuff I'll see y'all on the flip can't
you flip bye guys it was fun later